[Music]
no one ranked higher than Taylor Swift
when it comes to her paycheck
[Music]
and I'll write your name according to
Forbes is 2016 list of the world's
highest-paid musicians the 26 year old
banked more in the last year than any
other year of her career spare no
expense Forbes looks at a musician's
income between june first 2015 and june
first 2016 dealer brought in omega 170
million bucks it made it a really good
day here's how the rest stack up One
Direction is second on the list with 110
million but that has to be split between
all members of the band likely also
including Zayn Malik left in 2015 which
means Taylor's ex Harry Styles probably
made out with 20 to 30 million adele is
third with 80 point five million Madonna
comes in fourth with seventy six point
five million Rihanna isn't far behind
though at number five with a cool 75
million Garth Brooks ranked 6 on the
list with 70 million and check out these
rockers ac/dc is 7th bringing in 60 7.5
million while the rolling stones made 60
6.5 million Taylor's other ex Calvin
Harris made a whopping 63 million and
Diddy is at number 10 with 62 million
[Music]